right now it's a buyers market for
talent without a doubt anybody who has a
job is pretty happy about it and it's
probably not gonna rock the boat but if
you look into the future I think the the
the work environment is going to have to
change radically in many of the
organizations around the world that I
and I'm acquainted with you know I have
a Business School professor I get to
interact with a lot of MBAs and as I say
right now they're mostly happy to have
any job at all but in their hearts most
of them do not want to work any longer
for big and bureaucratic organizations
they want to work for companies that
that mirror or that honor the values of
the web that are open that are
meritocratic that are transparent that
are collaborative where there's a lot of
freedom and if you think about this this
Facebook generation if you like this
generation that grew up on the web
this is profoundly changing and shaping
the attitudes they have about work you
know what what are some of the the kind
of signal things that you learn when you
live your life on the web and let's be
clear for this next generation the web
is not a tool it's it's not something
that's kind of out there that you use
occasionally the web is the operating
system for their lives and so the values
of the web have infused their thinking
you know on the web if you upload
something to YouTube or you write a blog
or post a photo up on Flickr nobody asks
you whether you went to film school or
journalism school they just look at your
contributions that was it funny was a
beautiful was it incisive and so on but
you are very much evaluated on your
contribution not on your credentials
likewise on the web every idea competes
on an equal footing you'll remember the
old cartoon a few years back New York
for magazine has the dog in front of the
computer screen and the caption read on
the door on the internet nobody knows
you're a dog well on the internet nobody
knows you're a senior vice president
either and they don't care what matters
is your contribution not your
credentials
another kind of fundamental ethos of the
web is that all the leaders who emerge
on in the AI online world these are
leaders who aren't employed by somebody
these are leaders who emerge bottom up
by virtue of their service to the
community you look at any open-source
project you'll find people have more
influence and in shaping the evolution
of the project within the blogosphere
some blogs get higher authority ratings
than others based on how many people
link to them or how many times you know
somebody has kind of given them thumbs
up thumbs down with any within any
online forum their people have more
influence their views carry more weight
but all of these kind of natural leaders
they emerged not from some formal
appointment process they emerge because
people recognize their expertise
recognize the value they were adding the
service they were providing to that
community so think about what what is
that going to mean when this group of
people the Facebook generation comes to
work how likely is it that they are
going to want to work in organizations
that don't reflect the social values
that they've grown up in on the web and
I think the answer is not very likely at
all so I think a challenge for every
organization today if you think about
the the machinery of management we've
been using for the last hundred years
the way we plan structure organize
allocate hire motivate all of those
things we're going to have to to kind of
infuse the musty machinery of management
with the new values that we find online
the values of a set of collaboration and
freedom and transparency and meritocracy
and so on and any company that doesn't
do that there's not a chance five years
from now you're going to be able to hire
the best and the brightest talent from
around the world right now you may think
it's a buyers market it's not going to
be that way forever and the companies
that win are going to be the companies
that get that and start bringing those
values to bear inside of their
management processes today
you